my name is Romanova Valentina Iosifovna I was born in Ukraine on June 22, 1941, I met the war under bombing in Babi Yar, my relatives died on February 24, 22, I again meet Putin in Kyiv under bombing and shelling, take your troops and get out of Ukraine, we want peace [music] I don’t have words typing four generations of my family studied here suppressed and somehow let it lie and the Czech is not going on it’s not known where you will all be damned meanness to hate until the last breath in me it’s all the same and to win here the freak car just ran over the car of a person [music ] [applause] drop finished writing excellent [music] maybe you’ll tell me already 6980 then read about 40 it’s yes you will be born Ukraine tse my outskirts of the minds of people there but no well and about harm and now I’m talking mono hand to john to build [music] house apparatus cynologists pineapple 2 [music] people block the road with a milk truck [music] in the church, it seems like shouting which roads we will not quietly
it’s better that they are the guards
from being scared
follow my example and from I’m completely
retired and the view of the province takes me on a
rainy day I saw how to keep in the
army therefore we complete the Cossack batils of the
polyarchy all of them manage to win it in a
rustle help kept buy a stinger brush
and help the army noisy  a
gust of r.a.
[music]
hurried to jump this far
bunch of lil kate &
power
[music]
beg you beg your life
set call back hizar stop
this war
outlasted stalin and
outlive putin
russian ship
these [ __ ]